hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom livestream I'm Sal Khan from
Khan Academy for those of you all who
are new to this this is a homeroom that
we are doing every day as the name
applies to really stay connected during
these times of school closures Khan
Academy we realized that we have a role
we have a duty to step up when we saw
the schools closing and we said how can
we better support parents teachers
students around the country and around
the world in these really hard times
since we've been running parent webinars
teacher webinars putting together all of
our content from early learning we're
gonna talk a lot about early learning
today from early learning all the way
through elementary middle and high
school in ways and learning plans and
schedules that that can help folks and
then also to do this so that we could
stay connected and answer folks
questions and in kind of a live
synchronous way and this this time of
social distancing I do remind everyone
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in our position to
do so please think about making a
donation to Khan Academy every donation
matters I want to give special thanks to
several corporations that have stepped
up in the last several weeks as soon as
they saw the Kovach crisis was happening
they said hey we want to make sure that
you can stay up and running we were
running a deficit even before the crisis
and we continued to run a deficit but
the the support from these organizations
have made a big difference Bank of
America AT&T Google org Novartis and
fastly thank you so much and if any of
you can are representing corporations
please reach out to us I'm s Khan at
Khan Academy I adore you can anyone can
email me there if you if you think you
have an interesting way for us to get
sustainable because you could imagine we
were already running in a deficit and
then the crisis our traffic is about 3x
of what it typically is we're trying to
do more programs so we we need that
support so I am super excited about our
guest today we've had her on before but
she's got several really exciting
announcements that I have to say I was
just telling Caroline before this I'm
quite enthusiastic about some of the
stuff she's going to talk about so so
Caroline maybe I'll let you take the
floor you know you have a couple of
announcements tell us what's new at Kahn
Academy kids
or actually sorry remind folks what Khan
Academy kids is and they tell us what's
new sounds good yes so I lead the Khan
Academy kids team which is a program for
children ages 2 through 7
so preschool through grade 1 and it's a
comprehensive early learning program
that covers multiple subjects everything
from academic subjects like reading and
math and also social emotional
development and executive function
skills and our app includes thousands of
lessons and books and interactive
activities that kids can learn from and
so there is an adaptive learning path
that adjusts a child's level and then
there's a library that has the thousands
of lessons in it and today we have a lot
of new things that we've been working on
one is a big research study was just
announced and I can go through that and
then we also are announcing our teacher
tools launch in Khan Academy kids
version 3 a lot of good news here so
first of all tell us about the research
study sure sure so it was very important
for us to get an independent academic
study on our program to test the
effectiveness of it and we did a study
with professor David Arnold from the
University of Massachusetts and Amherst
and he just released his results
publicly and the study was a randomized
control trial study which is the gold
standard of academic studies where there
are two groups of randomly selected
students and one group gets the Khan
Academy kids intervention and one get is
the control group and so this was a
study of four and five year olds prior
to entering kindergarten and they were
from low-income families with an median
annual income of about $24,000 and so
what we saw was that in a 10-week study
the kids that were using Khan Academy
kids saw substantial increases in their
pre-literacy skills so
tested pretest with the test of
preschool early literacy it's a token
test and then post-test and we saw the
beginnings were really substantial they
were at the beginning of the study about
at the 34th presentó likely due to the
effects of poverty and then after the
ten weeks of using Khan Academy kids for
20 minutes a day they were close to the
national average at 47 percentile and so
the size of these gains are substantial
they're equivalent to what is typically
found in much more expensive
intervention so as an example the
phonological gains were comparable to
those found in an intervention of 25
one-to-one sessions with a professional
tutor so there's a lot of what you've
just said that I think is worth
unpacking and underlining I mean just
the first thing is ten weeks is not a
lot of time it's your point it was 20
minutes per day and that essentially
closed the gap between the students who
are performing a good bit below where
they need to be and getting essentially
to the national average if I heard that
correctly right right because students
particularly low-income students often
enter the first day of kindergarten and
they're already behind in these critical
pre-literacy skills which are things
like recognizing letters of the alphabet
understanding letter sound knowing their
letter sounds and understanding
phonological awareness skills being able
to break down sounds in words and
sentences so these are really critical
to learning how to read so they start
school behind and then they don't catch
up now I was super excited I mean this
is one of those things where I'm
obviously this is part of Khan Academy's
kind of Khadem e kids but Caroline and
her team are a bit of a mini team on
their own and so I sometimes I don't
know about these things until I hear and
and it was really really heartening you
know we always had an intuitive sense
that this was really valuable and I have
to say you know Caroline I was telling
you this before we got on the call I
have a five and a half year old as many
folks know and you know people might say
oh Sal's five and a half year old he
must be super motivated and academic
potty humor and and my wife says he got
that for me I don't
I don't know I think I'm quite
sophisticated but he's been he's been on
it so much and you know so intuitively
as a parent I gotta say it feels right
it is incredibly engaging for children
but it's not your just your classic
edutainment it is true standards aligned
tell us about kind of the work that's
put in to make sure that it is standards
aligned and engaging at the same time
mm-hmm
so Khan Academy kids each of our lessons
is aligned with national standards so
for preschool it's the head start early
learning outcomes framework for literacy
and math and then for kindergarten and
first grade it's the common core
standards and we've worked with
educators from the Sanford ed school who
are who specialized in early learning
and child development to make sure that
our lessons are aligned with standards
and also taught in a way that reflects
how really experienced teachers teach
these concepts in the real world and
what we've learned through looking at
the research on the learning of science
of learning is that technology has the
power to really further the learning for
children if it meets certain criteria so
it has to be active hands-on engaging
learning it has to give kids specific
real-time feedback and then it also
needs to adjust to a child's individual
level and that's what we've built Khan
Academy kids around those principles and
I want to emphasize to folks this is all
free this is all non-for-profit and I
think a lot of people are skeptical
about things like this they're like
there must be a catch I mean people have
thought that taught that about Khan
Academy but there's other resources out
there that are more than happy to charge
you you know five dollars a month ten
dollars a month you know buy an app for
this amount and you know I you know
anyone who doesn't believe me go
download the app and put it in front of
a two three four five six or seven year
old and you will see not only does it
work and keep them engaged and it's very
good for them but it has a lot more in
it than you would normally expect of of
an app I mean you touched on it there's
there's a ton of stories in there ton of
activities yeah that's
we've been hearing from parents is that
yes particularly during this time of
remote learning they are relieved to
find something that is so comprehensive
and then actually they can see their
children building their vocabulary
learning how to count I think we've
heard directly from parents who are
saying that they didn't realize that
technology could teach their child so
much but they're in these desperate
situations they found Khan Academy kids
and now after just a few days or weeks
of using it they're realizing that their
kids are really building these skills
and it's not only the academic skills
that are so important for this age as
Sal was saying his son is wants to play
until all kids at this age want to play
it so the way that we approach learning
is play based and entertaining as well
as engaging for for kids is like they
want to learn through stories and they
end songs and that's those are really
through play is how kids build some of
those critical new Murli numeracy
vocabulary and literacy skills and I do
want to remind folks if you have
questions start putting your questions
on YouTube and Facebook on the message
boards we have team members looking at
them I will get them to Caroline over
the course for conversation but there's
a few more things I want to just make
sure I have a chance to talk to Caroline
about I mean I do want to double down on
this you know my wife is a physician and
she was on physician some physician
mom's group and people were talking
about this age group and people saying
what should I use and a lot of parents
we're saying a lot of physician moms
we're saying kind of care to me kids
it's incredible it's free and it has way
more than you think but there are other
people who are saying oh you know this
thing that I'd pay $10 a month for my
wife is like I can't believe people are
paying money when this is available
especially and some of that stuff you
pay money for it's not as engaging it's
not as standards aligned and it doesn't
have the types of efficacy studies that
you just talked about and look you and I
are not selling anything we are funded
with philanthropic donations and I'll
say please donate so that we can keep
doing this but I you know if you have
young kids you shouldn't have to pay for
this and if you know people the young
kids make sure they know that this stuff
is available there for free you know we
don't have the marketing budget to tell
you know to put ads out on the world but
this is they're free and it's the most
high-quality resource Caroline tell us
about the other I mean
there's the announcement around some of
your teacher tools tell us about that
and I actually also want to make sure
people know about some of the
first-grade content you've added
recently as well tell us about what
you're doing from teachers sure so right
before school closures at the beginning
of March we launched a large update to
Khan Academy kids that included all of
the Common Core Standards for first
grade ela and math and then after school
closures on the heels of that we decided
to fast-track our teacher tools update
so we have just in the last week
announced our teacher tools and this was
really important for us because since
the beginning teachers have been
clamoring to use Khan Academy kids and
they've actually been which was
originally designed for families and
parents so parents set up an account and
so teachers were actually using the home
accounts to set up their students but it
really wasn't designed to support a
whole class and so these teacher tools
include easy ways for teachers to set up
their class with the teacher and
students and then to look at search all
of our lessons by standards so the
standards that they are teaching to they
can find the relevant lessons and then
assign lessons to their students and
then after their students have done some
of the lessons they can monitor how
their students are doing so which
students have completed these lessons
how they're doing what the scores are
and they can look at the assignments by
assignment or they can look at the
scores by student as well remote
learning there we've made it easy so
that teachers can just share a code with
parents at home so that the students can
learn at home on their devices at home
and then the teachers can continue to
send them assignments and monitor their
progress and this is so important in
this age because students really need
that connection with their teacher and
the teachers know best about what this
their individual students need to be
learning no I want to emphasize that 1a
parents can also use that functionality
and if you know as I was I couple days
ago I was like where is this
functionality that Caroline and Michael
had showed me and they're like oh I have
to update the app sister a reminder
update the
and then you will see this functionality
and there's instructions where can
people find instructions if they want to
understand how do they activate the
teacher tools or how do they assign
things if you just go to Khan kids org
we will have a link to our teacher tools
and we have modules like quick set-up
guide and things like that to walk you
through each of the different steps yeah
and I gotta say it's quite powerful
you're able to just look at the entire
library of thing by standards by grade
level and then just you can sample it
very nicely and say oh I can assign this
to to my students and you know I we I've
been talking to the my five-year-olds
teachers and it is amazing that it's
almost the exact you know I think
they're very thoughtful about what my
five-year-old needs to be doing right
now but you know but they're doing they
were doing primarily those you know kind
of classic worksheets but the stuff that
y'all have done
cover those same standards in so much
more of an engaging way an interactive
way and he frankly wants you know it's a
bit of pulling teeth to get my son to do
even one worksheet on you know in theory
that could take him like three minutes
to do but Mike you know I'm long ago
versus short oh and I'm like I'll just
just do it just you know but with the
same activity on Khan Academy kids he
like wants to do it after kind of pull
them off of it so you know if you can't
tell I'm very excited about the work
that Caravan this time I think you know
there's risk of academic loss during
this time without teachers and being in
school and so this is why we're so
motivated to do this work but we're
still heartened to see all this the kids
and parents that are writing in to us
with stories about how they aren't just
hungry to learn and they love learning
and they're sending us their stories and
they're sending us their photos of the
activities that they're doing yep so
there's two cup questions here from
Facebook Scott yang says hey Sal why
didn't you put the Big Bear behind you
today you know what Scott I'm gonna I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna go get coach I
was told I had to be on I think it was
CNN and one member of our team says well
you know Kody bear looked like he's just
kind of staring at you so so I'm gonna
get that but while I'm a while I
actually I'm gonna get that right now
I'm gonna give a question from Andrea
Adams [ __ ] Magette from Facebook how
can I ensure this is for Caroline how
can I ensure my five and seven year old
do not get addicted to tech during this
time of homeschooling online and I'm
gonna go get Cody sure look forward to
seeing Cody that is a great question I
think at the top of our minds we
designed Khan Academy kids to make sure
that it was developmentally appropriate
and not to focus on using technology for
hours and hours on end it's designed for
kids to be using and 5 to 10 to 20
minute increments depending on their age
and what's appropriate for them so some
ways that we've done done is there's go
game it is design activity so that after
a lesson you are coming back out and the
lessons are paced to be short increments
with an introductory video and then
highly active interactive experiences
and then after a few activities will
tell your kids to get up and sing this
song or dance and stuff or go outside
and take a look at the leaves or
something like that related to the story
so we really are cognizant of not having
it be an experience that just sucks your
kids in which a lot of adult technology
as we all know from social media and all
that is designed to be addictive so
we're on the converse designed to be
hands-on minds-on learning but not
sucking your kids in you can kind of
tell when they get that glaze over look
for things that are not active learning
and so we designed it to be active and
interactive another thing is I think
just being we have come out with some
schedules for kids just as a starting
point and every family is different and
has different routines but having some
structure to the day does help yeah
particularly with young children and
them knowing okay we're gonna have
reading time now and then in half an
hour we are gonna go outside and play
and so understanding that regular
routine and that those transitions that
are coming up can really help we really
okay balancing not only the Khan Academy
kids time but all the other learning
that they're doing outside and inside
the house and we've come up with some
programs to support that as well we
believe in the offline learning and have
some printables on our website as well
as activities that you can do with
materials in your house and then Sophie
and I from my team are hosting a circle
time where we encourage kids to get up
and dance and we read books with them
and do interactive activities that also
highlight the types of learning that are
in con kids and I'll say just as a
parent and you know this is literally
something that I observed this morning
and last night is you know when my son
is on a device he looks you know I don't
know if you can see me right now but you
know he looks kind of like you know he
kind of has this like you know when he's
just like watching YouTube he's just
like this you know and no parent wants
to see that on their kid too long where
he's just staring at it but when he's
doing kind of kid B kids there's
something about it where he's like yes
and he's moving around and he's dancing
and he's like I don't know I don't know
what it is but I definitely seen him
it's kind of feels like healthier
behavior then you know they're just like
you know tablet zombie-ism that you
sometimes see and you know what I would
add is you know no one is advocating to
do this hours a day I think your
research study was 20 minutes a day so
if you know I could imagine a couple of
10-15 minutes a day sessions it's plenty
to keep people keep progressing and if
you need time where your kids on the
screen this is a very healthy screen
time yeah we've designed it so that Cody
bear the one behind Sal talks to your
child and we've scripted the language
open-ended question so that kids that's
why the kids are talking back to the app
and tell you know talking about you know
what they're thinking and they're
learning yeah this just this morning we
my son was doing the subjects of
sentence and you know it was like you
know he wrote a bicycle to town and it
had a picture of Cody or a little
cartoon of Cody riding a bicycle and I
was like you know it says what's the
subject and you could tell he was
processing it because the you know
obviously was he and and and he's like
Cody's
riding a bike and this Cody is he he you
know and it was just really powerful for
for me to see that that that that
process going on I actually thought you
know being able identify subjects or
kind of verbs in a sentence was a little
bit beyond him at the stage he's it but
I was I was very very impressed with how
the app delivered it so the more
questions here so this is Dave Hank in
from YouTube says as a teacher I'd like
to know how you recommend introducing
Khan Academy kids to parent Guardians so
they'll buy into regular use as a
teacher I think now with our teacher
tools it would be a lot easier to get
them to buy into regular use as
particularly if you send them an
assignment or two a day then they will
know they're getting something from
their teacher and the students will be
able to see that assignment in their
view and you'll be able to see which
ones they've completed and how they've
been done in doing these assignments is
really quick you can just search by
standard or even just look through our
library and see which lessons are
aligned with what you like to teach and
then just press a button and it's
assigned yeah I have to say you know
what what I've seen for my own
children's school is they've been doing
a heroic job they have a learning
management system and they you know they
sent us printouts so but every morning
me or my wife we have to go print out
the worksheets then my child does them
then we gotta take pictures of them we
have text it uploaded it on to the
learning manager stressful for us some
some days but you could imagine now with
Khan Academy kids you can as a teacher
assign it and parents and families and
students just have to get in the habit
of like in the morning let's see what's
assigned and then they can beacon they
can go through that they don't have to
upload pictures and all this other stuff
that you have to do with worksheets and
this time of social distancing so yeah I
think as a teacher you have a lot of a
lot of power to forget to get get
families on it so a related question
Lauren buyer from facebook asks would
any of the teacher platform tools be
useful for parents to use at home
absolutely so particularly during this
time when all of you are home
schoolers absolutely if you want to use
Khan Academy kids the teacher tools all
you need to do is set up an account as a
teacher or if you're a parent and you
already have an account you can convert
it from the parent section we have some
documentation on our website on how to
do that yep from Facebook Scott yang
asked and I can help answer this as well
but Caroline who helped you oh well
actually the I I read this the wrong way
but I'll answer what I read it the first
way but Caroline tell us a little bit
about how Khan Academy kids was founded
is what starts asking I read funded the
first time I was going to answer that
too but um well so I founded a company
called duck duck moose about ten years
ago with my husband Michael and we
created 21 educational apps for mostly
preschoolers an elementary school a
elementary school and we did this
independently for about eight years and
then in 2016 we joined Khan Academy so
we have been part of Khan Academy since
2016 and focused on now on developing
Khan Academy kids although the duck duck
mousse apps are still out there and
they've been downloaded I think over
sixty or seventy million times yeah for
the I've oftentimes espoused my
benevolent alien theory that a
benevolent aliens are using Khan Academy
as a vector to prepare humanity for
first contact and when Caroline and
Michael reached out I guess yes but
awhile now four years ago and said we
you know the y'all had a presentation it
was kind of hilarious and I was like no
no I know all about y'all I'm your
biggest fan my kids are you know been
using duck duck mousse I've always told
the Khan Academy team the only time
we're ever gonna get into early learning
is if we can be anywhere remotely as
good as the duck duck moves team and the
fact that y'all were in the office is
like why are you here and that you and
Michael said well we'd actually like to
donate our organization to Khan Academy
and I was like all right benevolent
aliens thank you we get the message yeah
your earlier point about how we're
completely free we couldn't do that when
we were not a non-profit and when we
were
independent and so to us it was so
important for us to be able to focus on
the education for kids and not to
interrupt kids with in-app purchases and
subscriptions while they're learning and
to give you Michael and the team a lot
of credit
you had other financial options where
you guys could have gotten bought out
and it could have been very very
lucrative for y'all but this is
something that you just decided as
humanitarians that you wanted to you
want your life's work to be accessible
to as many people as possible and so
Caroline her Michael and her team they
passed up a lot of money that a lot of
us would have thought twice about in
order to make Khan Academy kids
not-for-profit effort and you know we
were able but obviously they were able
to donate their organization to watch
which was frankly worth many millions
arguably tens of millions of dollars and
but then we had to go find funders and
that's where at the time was called the
Omidyar Network Pierre Omidyar Pierre
and Pam Omidyar founder of eBay famously
his foundation was one of the major
funders that allowed us to do this work
and then the Windsong trust those are
the two really big funders that allow us
to do this work but once again we're
also running it as a deficit at the Khan
Academy kids level so especially if
you're a parent and you've really
enjoyed it please think about donating
and if you're a corporation or a
foundation please think about helping us
to support this work so from youtube
wendy Oliver this is more of a comment
but it's a good comment the offline is a
great feature for those families who are
remote or do not have access to the
Internet Caroline tell us more about the
offline functionality and you know what
kind of devices can this be used on if
people just have a cell phone is that
sufficient yes yes so we designed Khan
Academy kids to be accessible as widely
as possible on Android and iOS as well
as across different devices phones and
tablets and it was very important for us
to design so that folks with
intermittent Wi-Fi could use it so we
have an offline mode where a substantial
portion of our content and early
literacy and math can be accessed when
you're offline so you can you use all of
those lessons
for the complete library and the
Learning Path you do need an internet
connection just because of the thousands
of lessons there is no way that we could
pack it into a mobile app nor would you
want it all on your device but we've
also designed the technology so that it
downloads in small packets when you do
need new lessons for your learning path
and then it purges them so it's really
designed to be efficient so that anybody
on any devices can use them yeah and I
think that's you know just double down
you know we really obviously the whole
reason why Khan Academy exists kind of
Academy kids exist is to level the
playing field as much as possible and
there's all sorts of inequity right now
on device access and we're trying to
work with others to solve it but kind of
Quetta me kids goes arguably further I
mean our the Khan Academy main app so to
speak also has some ways to download
content but y'all do a really great job
it's as long as you have at least a
reasonable smartphone and have some time
to download some of the materials that
that you can go pretty far there's a
question about from Susan Garcia
Dominguez on YouTube is it available on
laptops or is it only tablets and phones
it is only on mobile devices right now
and the reason for that is that we found
in testing with young children that the
form factor of mobile devices where they
have the touch screen that they can
directly manipulate is much more
effective for learning it's it's tough
for the two-year-old and three-year-olds
to navigate before they can read on a
computer with it with a mouse yeah and
even the five and six year olds I mean
they can do it kind of but it's and that
leads to another question from Nikhil on
YouTube I feel like I know a lot of
these folks because we have good
question askers who show pretty Susannah
Nikki Scott almost every day but hi
South Caroline what are the best
studying methods while simultaneously
using Khan Academy
you know I'll interpret that as how does
Khan Academy kids you know transition to
Khan Academy I have a view there but I'd
love your take on what it is today and
maybe whether it could be in the future
uh-huh yeah I think right now it's we
cover up through the end of first grade
and then Khan Academy that does take
we're hoping to scale up through the end
of second grade at least
and that Khan Academy takes over from
there but we're building those those
critical skills in pre literacy and math
before you get into Khan Academy yeah
and if you go to Khan Academy there is
content on kindergarten first grade
second grade content but it does require
to use a mouse and it has things like
select all that apply
and so we view that content especially
in the world of where Khan Academy kids
exist that's valuable if you're a fourth
grader a third grader or if you have a
student who needs to over mediate some
of that content or review some of that
content but ideally if you are if you
are working on first grade that
standards are below Khan Academy kids is
the place to go and yeah I hope second
grade and you know third grade could be
an interesting thing too if we have the
resources to do it to think about
because because kind of Academy kids
really is I think hitting the sweet spot
for what those kids needs I see that my
own son when I when I put them on Khan
Academy they're using the mouse
you know the motor skills to kind of
click on the radio button is a little
bit more difficult than and obviously
what kind of Kevin kids he has no
problem no problem at all see more
questions I'm getting on so there's a
there's there's let's see other
questions this is from Madeline bodrero
on youtube I love that you see the super
simple songs and interactive component
component cheers to you and your team
and that's a good reason to talk talk
more about all the content and the
partners that we that we've been able to
write so grateful partner a lot of our
content is homegrown so we have our own
books that are illustrated by our own
illustrators but we collaborate with
children's book authors to author
original and original series of books
and then we also collaborate with super
simple songs which is an amazing
animation company that has I think I
don't know how many billions of views on
YouTube but favorite Nursery Rhymes and
great animations coupled with these
these songs and so we integrate them
into Khan Academy kids and then make
them interactive so we'll use the muffin
man song and then have children do
activities around that
in addition we partner with National
Geographic and bellwether which have
non-fiction books on animals and nature
and so that's how we have some of our
science content so more questions here
Marie says from YouTube Sal are you ok
you look tired are you ok I think it's
just relevant because Caroline looks so
energetic and well lit and yeah I'm
looking at myself now and I'm like yeah
that guy needs something it's all
relative I think what you don't see
Caroline I'm 9 I do circle time here so
I have to look away don't worry I think
Marie is onto something I need a I need
to introspect a little bit
[Laughter]
Rasika tell him steady from YouTube I
literally did my Khan Academy homework
right now love the detail videos all the
good to hear that rashiku let's see
other other there's someone there's
folks scott asking a lot of questions
hey Caroline would you like to invite
Sophie into a livestream with Sal
someday I guess supporters yes we'd love
to absolutely Sophie everywhere she will
only reinforce me looking like I'm tired
and aging and parent and teacher
webinars as well Marie you've confirmed
some of my insecurities so I don't know
I'm feeling a little I sometimes like to
think that I'm more young and Sprite
than I am
let's see there's there's a lot of
questions here but I digress we're out
of time I'm always I'm having a good
time with these conversations until
someone points out that I look old and
tired but but Caroline you tell us a
little bit more I mean what are your
hopes
I mean just to finish this up what are
your hopes and dreams for for Khan
Academy kids yeah I think we are just
grateful right now that we have a role
to play in our way to help families and
teachers during this time in particular
so we're
just very very focused on the current
moment and everything that we can do
this new teacher tools is extremely
exciting for us to see we are already
seeing districts and teachers use it
from California all the way across to
New Jersey and I think we were just at
the beginning of our classroom entry and
will continue that as well as with new
features for teachers and classrooms and
then we're very excited to continue with
the content we're seeing the kids grow
and they want to grow more with us and
so continuing on it's a second grade
awesome well I just want to thank
everyone I want to remind everyone go
try out Khan Academy kids even if you
don't have early learners at home
proselytized it tell other people
because it's a shame that they're and
you know tell them about Khan Academy
too there's still so many families
especially families of need that don't
realize that there are resources out
there for them and their children and
for their children's teachers to keep
folks learning and not only are they
free but there's more research studies
done on Khan Academy and Khan Academy
kids than almost all of those for pay
products that frankly are spending
probably more on marketing than they are
on product development and content
development and research and development
so get the word out it's really a shame
that people aren't accessing these
things or that they are paying for
things that are inferior frankly but I
want to remind everyone the way that
we're able to do this and kind of do
what's right on a principal level is
through donations so if you're
benefiting you your family or if you
just want other kids around the country
and eventually the world to benefit from
Khan Academy kids if you your children
your students or you want other people
around the world of benefit from Khan
Academy please think about making a
donation it makes a huge difference you
know one way to think about it if you
were to go to you know a not as good for
pay product it could easily cost ten
dollars a month
five dollars a month if you're able to
support Khan Academy those types of
levels it makes a difference it allows
us to support a lot lot more folks so
thank you so much for joining Caroline
thank you so much you Michael and your
entire team really amazing work and you
know thank you for dedicating your life
to this this is you did not have to do
this this is not the way that the world
normally works but y'all y'all decided
to do what's right for frankly you
yeah we're grateful for the opportunity
thanks everyone and we'll see y'all next
week we have a lot of really good guests
next week well and you'll will be
sending out emails and stuff but you
know we have a really cool folks like
Angela Duckworth and other folks next
week to talk about grit and resilience
so see y'all later have a great weekend
and take care of yourself clearly Murray
thinks I need to myself
you